mais c'est jeff bezos pdg d'amazon la
syrie n'a porté un plot aux séries ces
lettres lues sur la scène du théâtre aux
écuries ont été écrites dans une classe
de français de l'école sophie barat
monsieur françois legault michel
stringer enseigne un peu plus que le
français
depuis trois ans il aborde le pouvoir
avec ses élèves de quatrième secondaire
il faut une nouvelle loi de placement en
actions avant l'argent le juge gomery
aussi qui est venu c'était au parler
d'eux c'est quoi un esprit corrompus
comment on peut basculer à la corruption
justement cause du pouvoir pouvoir de
l'argent
votre argent vous confère autant sinon
plus de pouvoir que la majorité des
chefs d'état je pense que ça veut dire
c'était pas la wii avec la cram
évidemment c'est inévitable mais ne step
on a rapidement pu appeler ce français
barres obliques politique qui réflexion
je sais que le français a coûté cher à
garder
je suis fier de cette persistance quand
j'ai eu l'exercice et je me suis juste
dit bon ce week end pouvoir sur moi en
font les ja la famille le gouvernement
mais c'est le pouvoir y ait un peu
partout
c'est tout ce qui nous influencent à
faire quelque chose inconsciemment dans
le fond possible quand vous croire qu'on
dit que le troisième est à québec et de
projets verts n'est pas que des lettres
1 donc il ya eu aussi un exercice très
intéressant pour qu'edf puisse acquérir
du vocabulaire politique ce qu'est ce
que ça veut dire par exemple un coup
d'état
on s'arrêtait puis on construisait ce
glossaire politique et ça paraît sur
cinq
le conformisme une soumission se
soumettre à la norme dans la mire de ces
jeunes
les politiciens les magazines de mode
les compagnies pharmaceutiques les ultra
riches et les parents
j'ai plus envie j'ai pensé que ces deux
générations se sont battus en français
grâce à une subvention
trois professionnels ont transformé le
projet des élèves en spectacle
de voir les corps en mouvement de voir
un style grand nombre de jeunes en scène
baisse aussi ça parle du pouvoir dans le
pouvoir expliquer à ceux qui l'exercent
le veston comme symbole et la musique
composée par des élèves sont des
personnages qu'on envoie une invitation
françois degois justin trudeau à gabriel
nadeau-dubois man on nous a dit qu'il
viendrait
je trouve que ça serait tellement
intéressant d'avoir ce moment tout ce
qui vous reste à faire si d'avouer
moteur
les spectateurs auront de quoi être
habité par la lucidité et les espoirs de
ces jeunes pour quelques jours pour ceux
que le pouvoir
heureusement dans la rue
[Musique]
à la fiche d'ici dimanche ici à nourrice
despatie radio canada montréal